the Flyers this evening going with 11 Fords
and seven defenseman Atkinson Counterattack
a nice pass there and a save by cros excellent
little sace to farbe Morgan Frost just sort of
in the right place at the right time there he is
again denying M's pass set ahead this is McKinnon
racing in shot save by hard rebound Stu behind
the net up to Manson Big B teas it up looking
that shot never got through back it comes for
McKinnon down deep backhanded in front knocked
Away by the Flyers picked up by McKinnon that's
why he was 24th overall back in 2015 ABS Havoc
ciano Bobs that one up and out former Ottawa 67
former member of theia Sting here's Johansson in
deep shoots oh that puck went right off heart and
over his head as the ads had gone nine straight
games with at least one one power play goal and
then they've just been absolutely bankrupt on
that redirected save by hard rebound it's loose
stuff to The Far Side of marar will take over
again mckin one timer there that's wide of the net
just trying to find the Flyers leaning one way or
other in front of the post from Ron it's redirect
unlucky right now the ass Mo tried to fire it off
heart and heart actually duck to avoid that that
was amazing he saw it coming straight up top for
an and shoot save heart and it knocked the goal
stick out of his hand and the difference is all
these young Flyers are buying in and believing
the Old Guard is gone whack at cou down the slot
conne shoots and scores Travis connect his 15th
goal of the season and even though the ABS have
had a lot of the momentum in this game all it
takes is one broken play in a bouncing Puck
and ketne is able to convert comes out to Two
on Two play but connecting just somehow barely
slides in that's an unreal pass on the far
side from couturier who's one of their top
offensive guys obviously looks like a no looker
beautiful play by the Flyers as y have just get
caught a step behind and unfortunately
proov cannot bail the out out of Tage it
goes and he walks by Manson direct to the
tape of Nathan McKinnon down the left wing
this time McKinnon forhead safe score
Nathan M K took it all the way to the
front of the house to deliver the goods har
had it covered but not quite enough and the
ABS have tied the game at one and he was
flying well Nathan McKinnon is now scored
or assisted on the Avalanche last six goals
he's really put this team on his back right
now comes across so much speed Carter Hart
just very back into his net can't handle
that he underestimate how fast 29 comes in
slides out right under the seven hole on the
P hit the linesman in the skate there's a
turnover by Tatar Lon is in set down deep
save by Pros F oh my goodness yes and Ranson
had nothing in the zone there what did he do
instead of trying to make a tough pass through
it on net almost scor watch out here's th shoot
safe Pro theop Puck is Underneath Him and Fin a
whistle sort of play one way and that's North Sal
that's going to be a simple game that puck off a
stick off the glove and a sa Again by proov Off
the Bench it's wood he bangs it off for Manson
Josh Manson shoots deflected save over skated
by Colton hammered ahead tippet reaching shoots
save score Owen tippet gets his own rebound and
goes upstairs to get the Flyers a 2-1 lead
that was an all effort play for his ninth
of the Season he got his stick check now watch
here it's the rebound that Owen tippet grabs 27
goals last year a massive breakout year for the
fifth year Pro and you can see that Raw Talent
the length the speed 10th overall pick to Florida
back in 2017 but it's the rebound that's what you
hope a defensively can help you with or bros the
talk back to the evalan showa what's interesting
about Philadelphia rer they're probably going to
be maybe a borderline playoff teame in the East
it's going to be tough that's into the circle
shot score sanheim rips it home for his third
of the season and all the sudden Philadelphia for
the first time tonight has a two goal lead last
play in the net comes back down to the halfside
and just an absolute snap by sanheim who was
career high before this year was 35 points he's
on Pace for 60 he's absolutely taken control over
the backand here for the Philadelphia Flyer just
had a three-game point streak snapped I'd like to
see him get hot again but boy it nice to see a
healthy Manson back in the lineup certainly is
Johansson wins this drw Manson looking wrist
shot St as driker and you shall receive Josh
Manson fires one from the blue line and it's now
a 3-2 game for Manson the ABS need did it in the
worst kind of way well I like when players make me
look good and Josh Manson is just finding his form
he can hit he can fight and folks he can score
just lays that little wrist in there like kale
Mard loves to do the important thing is through
a screen he knows he sees two Flyers he sees k
r in front and that's the key all he's got to
do is find that hole and the Flyers have only
surrendered one short-headed goal this year that's
batted out here comes big bow he's got miles wood
with him gets it aead one shoot sa rebound
oh my goodness it hopped over the plade in
Theus well stall saved the goal cuz he got a
stick right on valus and again a wide open net
missed I can't believe how lucky Philly got it's
a breakaway for far in Saved by Pro Reb saved by
Pro that was actually Cam Atkinson who was sprung
the glove blocker then right here not one save Mo
but two look at this toe safe the strength to
keep that pad up there and keep that puck out
of the net the athleticism is unreal not there
but there wow highlight of the game absolutely
Pros vov strong with that left skate all the way
kep it in turned it over K on the Move McKinnon
chasing him conni is in Puck is free and a penalty
coming up watch out is this a penalty shot it
is well here we go I think it was that hand
around the last ketne gets the go-ahead at
Center ice this year in a shootout he's
up for one rosov out of his crease conect
me slow moving in shoots score it went off
proov and craia very unfortunate I thought
he saved it it sounded like it hit the pad solid
connect's coming in so slow he's absolutely just
feeling it and how does that go off the toe
and up and over it's almost like a turn the
pad on him watch this MOJ goes in hits the
top right corner of that pad and almost has
Top Spin on it to jump over unlucky there for
cros that's the second penalty shot goal for
the Flyers this season it did it turned the pad
it hit the pad the pad turned a little bit left
the defenseman will jump in at every opportunity
that pass miss the targets yeah you're 100% right
Bros must do better be ready cuz there's
some odd man rushes coming his way still
as a are going to let all their deed right for
goals sanheim with a centering pass give it on
score fary with the tally on a goal
mouth scramble and all of the sudden
the Philadelphia fers have busted It Wide
Open come going to throw everything at the
house just sliding right around the outside and
then there's chaos in front there's Bobby Brink
throws it who his line mate Fair Bean Taz is
in the back having a melee and that's just
everybody going to the net for Philadelphia
them finding the puck swarming that net with
too much heat in action and fairby just scores
an easy one in a wide open net former Pioneer
Bobby Brinks going to get the assist on that
play is Tas slammed ahead like Jack Johnson
icing waved off and why not that will do it
here at Balin as the ABS fall to Philadelphia